hi how you doing I looked up your
information in the phone book my name is
Cory Jones I'm the owner Gotti Atelier
here in Los Angeles California it's fine
jewelry specific to street wear
enthusiasts I run my business using
QuickBooks for my expenses so it's
pretty easy
alright let's try it out I'm sure okay
[Music]
alright guess why these lobes uh I'll
get to work sort these own normally I
would already have them in the software
but clearly this doesn't have a software
that I use
[Music]
all right that's it forever profit loss
statement now it's time to categorize
our expenses and generate a profit loss
statement
I haven't used a pencil and pad since
college man what am i doing
this is taking way too long basically
just fill out an invoice form it's not
his thing it's like I'm accustomed to I
don't know how anybody can do this
without QuickBooks in the 80s or even
now like I have to use snail mail since
I can't email I don't know how long it'd
take like a week to get there like okay
we are done left iced over
it was a great experience for sure but
you can have it all the things I did
today the expenses the invoicing I'm
able to do that on QuickBooks I don't
have to sit down and write things out
everything's automatically uploaded if I
was doing this alone back in the 1980s I
probably would need an assistant maybe
two of them